[Music]
to enormous reclaimed palm islands
stretched ten kilometers out to sea with
a third even larger one under
construction
these mini cities took six years to
create using millions of tons of rock
and sand 8,000 deluxe mansions and
apartments have been built housing
80,000 people the palm islands increased
Dubai's beaches by an astounding 112
kilometers but this is not enough for
the projected expansion of this emirate
investors want more not just their own
houses in the Sun but their own islands
so the Sheikh comes up with his boldest
plan yet a design far more complicated
than the palm he will build an island
chain in the shape of the whole world
an iconic global landmark surpassing all
Dubai's previous projects Lewis R Jamil
the master planner knows the world could
be the most unique structure on the
planet there's nothing like this
anywhere we tried to find anything that
of comparable scale that's been made by
man it has never been done this
literally has never been done for future
investors the world is the perfect
project a blank canvas to build your own
private dream in a highly exclusive
environment millionaire developers from
Island Raymond and Andrew know a good
thing when they see one we've been
watching this whole development being
created we think it's fantastic think
it's going to become the top tourist
destination in the world and why not
invest in it they snap up Island for a
cool 38 million dollars before it even
exists
their plan is to build the Emerald Isle
in the Sun a three-bed house will cost
two million dollars but the world
project is a long way off it will take
five years to create the islands and
another two before there are houses on
them sultan bin salam knows its Dubai's
biggest undertaking i felt worried
because this is never been attempted but
being so passionate about the project i
said i think we can do that the original
plan was to create the seven continents
in single sections but the Sheikh
quickly realized that no one will buy
such big plot instead he decided to
divide the world into lots of little
sandbars each investor can have their
own private island
Hamzah mustafa is the man who has to
deliver the sheiks dream he knows just
how important the project is to devise
future there was an element of fear this
is an ambitious project and this is a
project that will put Dubai on the map
when it's built 300 sand islands will
rise out of the sea future investors
will be able to buy their own part of
the globe anywhere from England or
France to the different States of
America